aux caves du roy la boîte ultra snoeck
de saint tropez ou danse des baronnes au
nom de trombone on essaie d'être à
l'avant-garde et si on ne fait pas la
mode
on la suit au plus près
à suivre ce samedi une compétition qui
n'est rivalité entre deviner puisqu'il
s'est mis non cette année la mode est
aux indiennes aux indiennes romain
lecomte a roulé sa mythique eu des états
unis si tu peux la faillite le pleure
c'est pas un peu futile j'étais un peu
futile mais
mais vraiment cher au maire et si
l'année prochaine c'est la pilote de
zouaves est-ce qu'une pantene pilote
portrait sa trompe et la provocatrice la
verte presse qu'il serait un de ces
lieux où règne le malin sodome et
gomorrhe entre pizza étant pérignon
c'est en substance ce qu'affirme le
roman de bronze à sparte huriez les eaux
de ramatuelle un livre à clé dans lequel
les tropéziens sa mise à se reconnaître
pour les uns un reflet de la réalité
pour les autres ouvrages excessive nous
avons rejoint l'auteur dans sa maison
tropézienne c'est cette europe 1 qui a
lancé la provocation le goût du scandale
qui est passé au delà des tabous des
préjugés
ces centres ep maintenant c'est devenu
banal c'est un monde entier il ya saint
tropez dans les yvelines et un château
mais il reste à saint tropez la beauté
du pays la chaleur le vin rosé et le
fait qu'on viennent du monde entier pour
voir cette débauche ou pour y participer
c'est exprès vous prenez ça trappe et
attire ceux qui veulent se mêler aux
vices ou au moins en respirer l'odeur
alors c'est un climat explosif c'est
comme certains microbes où il se
développe ou moins dans un climat gris
dans un climat froid équine dans un
climat très chaud avec des boîtes de
nuit merveilleuse car la vie nocturne à
sa trempe les hits est très amusant
entraîner